Iran has unveiled what it says is its
first domestically made Hypersonic
ballistic missile named fatah it was
revealed at a ceremony attended by
President Ibrahim raisi and top
commanders of the Revolutionary guard
Hypersonic missiles can fly on a complex
trajectory at least five times faster
than the speed of sound that makes them
difficult to be intercepted
daughter Jabari joins us now live from
Tehran Dawson tell us about this
development of a Hypersonic missile
well this is the first in Iran's
ballistic missile Arsenal it was first
announced by the Aerospace division of
the Revolutionary guard back in November
and finally today it was unveiled to the
high-ranking officials in the capital by
the head of the Aerospace division of
the Revolutionary guard Commander Amir
Ali he said that this was a
Monumental day for Iran's defense
capabilities we also heard from Iranian
president Ibrahim raisi at the ceremony
and he had the message to Regional
countries that it should be a joyous
occasion for them as well because as he
saw at this development of the first
Hypersonic ballistic missile in Iran
it's an occasion to understand that it's
for deterrence purposes it's something
that will protect not only the Iranian
Nation but also Regional countries from
what he called aggressive countries that
are trying to destabilize the region he
may call it parents but what do we make
of the timing of the announcements what
with the U.S Secretary of State arriving
in the region and Iran expected to
reopen its Embassy in Saudi this week
yeah
well it's certainly not a coincidence I
think this was a very much
um choreographed event to buy the
Revolutionary guard and the defense
Ministry to announce this development on
a day when Iran is supposed to open its
Embassy in Riyadh but also the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony Billington
will be in Saudi Arabia to discuss also
Iran's nuclear Ambitions as well as its
defensive capabilities the other issue
is that there is a event coming up in
October there's a U.N security Council
embargo on Iran purchasing or selling
any advanced technology related to its
ballistic missile program that
resolution is due to be lifted in
October as a result of the 2015 nuclear
deal the Iranians making this
announcement of the first ever
Hypersonic ballistic missile certainly
aimed at proving that their advancements
continue despite the limitations that's
been set on them by the International
Community and also they're opening up to
the global market this technology will
be technically up for sale in October
when that U.N security Council embargo
is lifted so it's a message both of the
turns and also that Iran's defensive
capabilities will be up for sale as well
dorsa Jabari there in Tehran thanks very
much dorsa